لقد قيل إنك ورثت موقفًا
معقدًا
للغاية مع كبار العلوم النووية في إيران حيث
كان
العالم قد اغتيل للتو في
هجوم قاله مسؤول أمريكي كبير لـ
CNN
أه يُنسب إلى إسرائيل
كيف يؤدي هذا الاغتيال إلى تعقيد
جهودك
للحصول على  إعادة الانضمام إلى الاتفاق النووي
بصراحة تامة ، من الصعب تحديد
مدى
تعقيد أول شيء سأحاول
القيام به وقد تحدثت الآن مع أكثر من
20 رئيس دولة أه لقد
أوضحت لأصدقائنا في الناتو  المكالمات الأولى
التي جاءت في
أن لدينا قاعدة لرئيس واحد
في كل مرة لذلك لا يمكنني
صنع سياسة ولكن أريد إعادة تأسيس
علاقات التحالف الوثيق التي كانت لدينا
في كل من
أوروبا والمحيط الهادئ وجزء
منها يتعلق  إن القدرة
على إعادة أوروبا إلى جانبنا في أوروبا
الآن لديها سلاح قوي في الأساس للولايات المتحدة
بناءً
على احتضان الرئيس للحكام المستبدين
والتمسك بدس إصبعه في أعينهم
ولذا أعتقد أن الأمر سوف  يعتمد كثيرًا على
ما سيغير الظروف إذا
جاءت أوروبا جنبًا
إلى جنب مع الولايات المتحدة ، لكنها
ستكون مفاوضات صعبة ، ليس
لدي أي أوهام حول ذلك ،
وخلاصة القول هو أنه
لا يمكننا السماح لإيران بالحصول على الطاقة النووية
الأسلحة وانظر إلى أي مدى أضر
الرئيس بهذه السياسة وذهب
لأنه انسحب للحصول على شيء أكثر صرامة
وما
فعلوه لقد زادوا من قدرتهم
على
امتلاك مواد نووية يقتربون
من القدرة على أن يكونوا قادرين على ذلك.  لديها ما يكفي من
المواد لسلاح نووي ،
هناك مشكلات تتعلق بالصواريخ ، كل تلك
الأشياء التي أعتقد أنها ستكون صعبة للغاية ،
لكنني أعرف شيئًا واحدًا
لا يمكننا القيام به بمفردنا وهذا هو السبب في
أننا يجب أن نكون جزءًا من مجموعة أكبر
تتعامل ليس فقط مع إيران ولكن  مع
روسيا
مع الصين ومجموعة كاملة من القضايا الأخرى